you know if you find that you're
struggling in certain areas of life
obstacles you know get in the way of
things you know sometimes the obstacle
can become the way that's it's basically
a book by Ryan holiday the obstacle is
the way
um which is a good read which I'd
recommend but you don't need to suffer
you know pain will come you will make
some bad choices debt was a painful
problem for you you found a solution
like that's what guys do lean in the
paint don't amplify the suffering stop
telling yourself you know yourself
stories a lot of guys would just be like
well that chick she just took advantage
of me and I did everything for her and
then she went and banged some guy in a
yacht because he dm'd like you know
that's you know that's like the victim
mindset that's like the story that you
want to tell to sort of you know keep
dealing with the pain it's like just
move on from it right
cool